okay Jags great win I miss confused as  you are but I think it has something to  do with being outside the country so  I've arranged that my next game even  further it's gonna be on the moon Wow  well we get there the moon's like a  whole nother planet I figured out how to  win two Super Bowls Eli Manning I think  I could figure out how to get a football  team to outer space Leonard as a human  science major at LSU I've been tasked  with designing our spaceship I present  to you the portal rocket okay Blake the  controls are based on your awkward  throwing motion so there's only a 58  percent chance that this journey ends  the completion McCowan's over there what  are we have arrived  this ship is calibrated for garbage time  all right now we can bring in a real QB  or proven veteran who's been to the  playoffs  I'll give you Brian NASA